what does man up mean to you uh man up
just simply means to me to human up as
in human up to your Highest Potential I
think as humans we're not all created
equally in other words many of us 95% of
us maybe even greater operate as human
animals impulsive instinctive reactive
selfish necessary for
survival however
Consciousness dictates that we evolve to
our highest self
that we become selfless that we become
servants and that there is no users's
manual the teaches Chris how to go from
Human Animal to human being being
Consciousness Radiance Connected To
Source or Creator right and so man up I
manned up my way which is why that was
the title of my book manned up my way to
becoming a better human less emotional
more responsive less
reactive and that led to becoming a
better leader better entrepreneur better
husband better father led to overcoming
many of my childhood traumas sexual
abuse physical abuse um but I can tell
you that when you man up to your higher
self or human up to your higher self uh
it's it's a gift it's a gift and we all
start as human animals because I believe
that is our number one purpose we have
to first de and work through to then
find our true purpose to serve Humanity
I'm feeling the word Ascend here you
know to transcend yeah to become better
than your base instincts to transcend
and include in uh Wilbur and language
yeah it's uh I think an awful lot about
how at the mercy of the confused
chemical signals of our body we are you
know the the reason that we do many
things is because of the paths of leas
resistance or societal Norm nors or what
we learned when we were a kid or the way
that we dealt with past traumas or that
thing that we want right now yeah and
that to me doesn't feel like Liberation
that feels like slavery it is it is
modern day slavery uh and I do believe
that the opposition you know news media
big Pharma military-industrial complex
food industry the government certainly
controlled by all those elements uh have
a oppressive benefit they have a they
have a reason to oppress humanity and
keep them as human animals as dependent
and needy and reactive and emotional as
possible because that is how you then
manipulate and get control and
compliance so I had this conversation
with Eric Weinstein a couple of months
ago
about the objective of modern media is
not to convince you of any one
narrative but to make belief in all
narratives be less certain and I I don't
disagree I think that fire hosing as a
tool is very useful in making people
uncertain about the future yeah what I
couldn't get to and Eric couldn't either
was what is the end goal usefulness of
that because I don't just see people
being uh pliable complicit compliant
citizens I have seen as many if not more
people use their new distrust in
mainstream media and farma companies and
so on and so forth I've seen as many
people use that as the activation energy
to become almost Rebels as I have people
roll over backward and say Please Mr big
government just tell me what to do so I
was skeptical at least a little
skeptical that this
strategy is either achieving the
outcomes that they meant or is actually
coordinated because it doesn't seem to
be making appliable populace as far as I
can see do you get where I'm coming from
here I I do but I do wonder is it
because of the circles that you're
running in that you see more people who
are rebellious against this does that
make sense a friend a friend group of
middle fingers yeah if we were to go
hang out and and I'll use this term
exactly as I mean it with the peasants
of humanity the majority the unwashed
masses the Human animals they are the
majority you would see that we and the
circles that you hang out with are the
minority it's just our circles consist
of people who are rebellious who are
freethinkers who are sovereign who will
give the middle finger to the man that's
we are the minority do you think you
need to be cautious of using words like
like the the the peasantry of humanity
the unwashed masses do you worry that
that might be dehumanizing sometimes no
because I hope that that is triggering
to most so that they will understand the
point that I'm making I love Humanity I
will fight for
Humanity and I and I pray that the
masses stop living at the bottom of the
mountain and take the journey to the top
because when they do as we talked about
earlier Transcendence takes place but
first they have to get triggered first
they have to be told what no one else is
willing to tell them that they are the
unwashed masses that they are slave
labor that they are there to just work
be in Debt Pay taxes die lose a majority
of your inheritance to the government so
that your kids can repeat the cycle that
should piss them off enough to want to
transcend in the process will I get some
hate messages absolutely I'm not a
stranger to
that yeah it's
uh Alex hosi is the guy that I think
taught me most about nudging
your view of activ ation energy from
just being something which has to be
positive some to being able to use
something which is actually a really
negative fuel source to kick you out of
the bottom so his idea
is people need some sort of motivation
some sort of justification to make
changes most people have way more pain
than they do pleasure use what you have
right and and that is absolutely true
and resentment of you resentment of your
message resentment of you of being
accused of being the unwashed mass
peasantry is also part of that
activation energy well Tony Robin says
that more people take action to avoid
pain than to gain pleasure and so we
know that to be true and as I say those
words make no mistake about it and I
talk openly about this I was peasant
class I was beyond blue collar I was the
unwashed masses I was the guy that was
dependent on government when I came here
from the Soviet Union lived in Section 8
housing had medical and
Medicare sought out the cheapest ways to
live because I wasn't prepared to do my
part and so I was that guy and had I not
had a mentor in my early 20s who slapped
sense into me this very way uh I I don't
believe I would have had that Awakening
and I believe it's our job to pay it
forward so you had at a uh hard love a
tough love Mentor which presumably
shapes how you then look to Mentor
people moving forward yeah I would say
so Jim Franco was definitely a kogy old
East Coast guy entrepreneur who
definitely mentored me with hard love
why do you think the story that we tell
ourselves influences our lives so
much well the story that we tell
ourselves is a byproduct of what
happened to us what's what people tell
us like oh well you're you're big boned
you've always been clumsy you've you've
you know everyone in our family is fat
you know like this this is thing what
I've heard I'm not pointing to you per
se I'm just pointing to myself like this
is what I've heard right so if that's a
story we start piecing together what an
identity oh this is if that's my story
this must be my identity I'm clumsy Big
Bone supposed to stay fat not supposed
to be active clumsy okay got it now that
I know that's my identity which by the
way is a false identity we we we go into
life looking for evidence to validate
that identity and you will always find
what you're looking for yeah yeah the
reticular activating system is one hell
of a drug you know you buy a new car you
see that every why how there were never
these many cars on the road before it's
because you're looking for it yeah yeah
uh I heard a really phenomenal quote a
year ago to do with cynicism uh people
with low self-esteem will always find a
way to be miserable yeah and it's
this predisposition that you have to
look for the thing that you you're
looking for confirmation bias the world
is the way that I predicted it to be we
were talking earlier on about control uh
and the fact that there is a a comfort
in knowing and even if that knowing is
Bing in even if that knowing is not
accurate or useful if it feels like it's
predictively correct because you can
warp what you see to retrofit what you
believe you end up with a world that
feels like it's in control yes and when
you feel like you have some sense of
control then you have less stress less
anxiety Etc now you may not have a
quality of life mhm at least a great
quality of life you may not have great
income you may you may not be of the
best health but at least it fits your
locus of control and and and you're able
to have some
predictable results someone your
neighbor in the very next house could
have a very different life experience
because of how they view the world even
if the material cons conditions are
exactly the same correct yeah I mean
this example from Sam Harris is so
phenomenal so everybody has done a tough
workout where up into zone five heart
rate and they've got the taste of metal
in the back of their throat and they're
lying on the ground doing a sweat angel
that even though objectively it's an
uncomfortable feeling is oddly
satisfying because of the story you tell
yourself about what that means I deserve
this this is making my body better if
you had that sensation spontaneously
arise in traffic
you would jump out of the car and try
and go to the hospital right you would
think that you were having some sort of
heart attack dripping with sweat and a
heart rate and all this stuff so that
proves that the story you tell yourself
about the present moment largely
determines your experience of it and I
think it's the is it the seven or nine
most meaningful words in all of uh
philosophy uh the universe itself is
change uh the universe is change and
life itself is what we deem it life
itself is what we deem it that's exactly
exactly right it's the story that we
tell ourselves now it is shaped by those
who raised us and had influence over us
and that we work for ETC but it is
ultimately life it is what we deem it
and and and so you have to
be relentlessly protective of the
information that you take in the
thoughts that occupy your mind the
people that you surround yourself with
because all of those things are
influence factors another stoic uh
philosopher once said that you know when
you leave your house and when you come
back that night you come back as a
different man you're never the same
coming back right well you're either
coming back as a better human more
Transcendent more aware more more
connected or
not I think this is this kind of
holistic view of personal development
you can fold masculinity and and sort of
manhood into this whether it's third
wave manosphere or you know ethical uh
personal development whatever term you
want to give it I think this is really
taking hold at the moment because
especially men have started to realize
the hustling grind until my eyes bleed
culture has its place but is also
unfulfilling in itself if I can't have a
relationship with someone that I care
about if I can't open up about my
emotions if I can't deal with my past
traumas like the renaissance man is the
guy who is able to tap into it all you
know uh that is happy to go out and do
fantastic in business tell people
difficult things stand up for himself
make decisions without being fearful and
then go home and let his little girls
draw on his face you know like it's that
and that Duality that softness and that
hardness I think is what really makes
you you know physically fit mentally fit
mindful aquanus all that stuff yeah uh
and that's I think that it's a good the
subculture that I at least begin to see
burbling under the surface with regards
to uh men's mental health role models
and stuff like that I think is beginning
to find its feet
yeah it really is and I'm a forever
Optimist and I can tell you that we're
seeing more men realizing that it's not
just about the car the watch the
possessions working until my eyes bleed
um at the project this thing that we run
a men's personal development program we
have the five pillars and it's Faith
Family Fitness finance and fulfillment
uh obviously the finance is what most
people think about right well if I just
make good money I'll be a good provider
is a man most men think that they're
relegated to just being a provider well
I provide a roof over their head they're
safe they have food they have school
supplies but there's more to being a man
you know there is more to being a man
what about a level of Faith as in
confidence in yourself Faith In Yourself
faith in a higher power that there's a
path for you right faith in your friends
and your circle of influence that these
guys who set up this amazing studio can
set it up in a way that we can have this
moment right so then you've got your
faith you got your finances great
what about Fitness and on the fitness
side I believe that physical fitness is
the gateway drug to emotional and mental
Fitness most people who do get fit
physically completely neglect mental and
emotional hygiene and they are living
stressed overwhelmed addicted to Vices
or financially broke because they
completely forgot about the other F
pillars and so that Fitness is really
about can you be physically fit because
think about what level of focus
consistency delayed gratification
discipline that is required for a man to
get lean jacked and stay lean and jacked
for a prolonged period of time that's a
lot of you got to do in terms of
how you eat how you train your nutrition
your sleep Etc your environment and that
bleeds into well maybe I can have some
greater control going back to locus of
control I can have some greater control
over my mental health emotional
discipline and so if we can factor that
then then what do we have left well we
got family because if you have money
you've got mental physical emotional
Fitness and you've got some level
of you know ability to have experiences
and go places and bit of material
Freedom yeah but you don't have anyone
to enjoy it with yeah what do you think
about this you know you you talk to and
speak to a a type of man you know that I
think could be categorized as uh
dominant lean in Alpha in some regards
there is another group of guys on the
internet who would also categorize
themselves as Alpha who are very anti-
family creation who are uh looking
toward women and giving advice to men uh
that uh the opposite sex is someone to
be avoided at all costs or to be uh used
and discarded to be treated as uh
transient transactional objects how do
you see this sort of world of you know
Red Pill Man spere men's advice with
your perspective given that you work
almost exclusively with men yeah yeah I
I truth be told man I I despise most of
that red pill world and to say that look
you know all women are bad and all women
want to use you and all women are
chasing down the dudes with the Lambos
and the watches and the money that is
not that is not true that is not true
again that that is you will always find
evidence for what you're looking for in
life and so if these young kids are
seeing that on YouTube right I say young
kids in their 20s late 20s even 30s I'm
49 what do you got I mean what do what
do you got so you got a life where
you're lonely the number one category of
suici suicide is men over the age of 60
who are alone so that's what they're
preaching in other words be alone just
have sex move on have sex move on and at
some point your value as a man you've
become old and now you're alone you
don't have a life partner the highest
category of suicide for men is men over
60 who are alone either divorced or
widowed or never found anyone so like
that's the end game they're preaching
that's stupid the the highest level of
fulfillment is not it's not stuff it's
not even
Legacy it's actually having
children and seeing those children
become great members of society value
adds to society knowing that when you
pass that is the Legacy you leave behind
like I've got Andrew and Khloe a son and
a daughter who will do so much more good
for this planet than I ever did cuz I
got such a late start mhm whereas they
started off my wife and I poured into
them from day one to be just Servants of
humanity but to also be Savages in terms
of expectations for themselves right and
so that is the greatest Legacy and so
without my wife how can I have those two
beautiful children and even if I were to
adopt them I can't give them the love
that a mom can give the nurturing the
safety I can give them what a dad can
give and so it's necessary that we
connect and so these dudes that get
behind a microphone and a camera and
they preach this is just hurt
people hurting more people it's all it
is and there you know that happens I
think a lot of what I'm
seeing and this isn't to say that
everybody needs to have kids there is
absolutely a cohort of people out there
for whom they can get to old age and the
end of their life without a family and
maybe make the right call and say that
that was the right call but not having a
life partner right to me seems you have
to be an unbelievably rarified stru of
human to say oh it's just me and my
paintings and my cats or dogs or
whatever uh and you know this
Perpetual sort of juvenile world uh it
doesn't seem heroic to me it doesn't
scream highest service it doesn't scream
you know overcoming my base instincts
giving back to to the world and Humanity
it's like this sort of
endless immature honic like
sludge that you just keep pumping into
yourself and what I also see
is like an industrial strength cope
that's used by these people to try and
retrofit meaning into their life through
other areas right you know look at the
people who are obsessed by
politics or obsessed by the Deep state
are obsessed by conspiracy theories are
obsessed by comic books whatever
it writes something because they need to
imbue meaning into their life through a
vehicle because they do not have that
coming from a significant other and or
kids that come along with it we are
hardwired to search
out find develop our purpose we're
hardwired for that and in the absence of
it so you don't have a life partner you
don't have children which are the two
two of the highest source of purpose and
then your vocation would be probably the
Third highest source of purpose in the
absence of that you begin to glom onto
something I don't care if it's antifa or
black lives matter or some the new
gay flag that's you know it's
got triangles and and whatever I don't
care if you want to be a transgender
unicorn like I'm all Fort man fly your
freak flagged however the people that
are so locked on to that as their
purpose are locked on to that because
they are lacking true purpose and
meaning and fulfillment in their life
and so you're forced to glom onto
something because the absence of purpose
means you are going to be addicted to
Vices pornography Vape alcohol whatever
the thing might be and that's how we
start spiraling into anxiety and
depression and self-loathing we'll get
back to talking to bed Ross in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about element element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium it is a
tasty alternative to sugary electrolyte
drinks that I've been using for over 3
years now it is the exclusive hydration
partner to Team USA weightlifting I'm
relied on done by tons of Olympic
athletes and high performers all around
the world you need to make sure that
your hydration is sorted and this is the
best tasting and best solution that I
have ever found I'm absolutely in love
with this orange version which is like a
sweet sweet nectar you can have every
single day best of all there is a no BS
no questions asked refund policy where
you can buy it 100% risk-free And if you
do not love it for any reason they will
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you'll love it
head to the link in description below or
go to drink LM nt.com slod wisdom to get
a free sample pack of all eight flavors
with your first box that's drink LM
nt.com
slod
wisdom you talk a lot about inner voice
and kind of the relationship that you
have with that inner voice it's
something that I've changed an awful lot
in myself over the last 5 to 10 years
let's say that there's someone listening
who says all right bed Ross seems okay
for you you have got a lot of freedom
and you're evidently friends with the
person that exists inside of your head
what would you say to someone who has a
bad in a voice and wants to change it I
think the very first place to start is
to understand that we are very unique
creatures on this planet we live on
three different planes don't we and my
dog cookie has no idea about that only
we have
self-awareness we have the sense of
purpose and we live on three planes the
physical plane like this is a vehicle
this you know your body is a vessel a
vehicle and it's deteriorating no matter
what you do take all the drugs you want
all the hormones you want time will
always wi entropy will win right exactly
so we live on that physical plane but
we're also energy we're Radiance we're a
soul we're a spirit we're
energy and then somewhere beyond between
those two there's the thoughts feelings
and emotions that you have so you're
living on life on three planes and as
you get older assuming you're doing the
work because wisdom is not just age
wisdom is experience compounded by age
there you have wisdom so literally your
soul your Consciousness gets wiser as
your body begins to deteriorate and this
is why you hear old folks always saying
if I could just go back like what do
they say age is wasted on the youth that
term exists because if I just
knew what I know now then oh my gosh
what I could have done in my 20s they
say right and so we have to reconcile
the fact that the vehicle is dying the
vehicle that I'm in is dying yet I have
greater self-control greater
self-mastery more in line with what my
god-given
source purpose
is and there I still have thoughts
feelings and emotions and I have to
master those so that I could keep
driving towards my god-given purpose as
my body is deteriorating and so the
inner voice is constantly fighting with
those three factors the human animal
Consciousness the physical being that
breaks down and gets sick which they
should take care of Eat Right workout
Etc and then the thoughts feelings and
emotions because they are living in
congruently the reasons our negative
selft talk exist is just that's your
conscience your conscience has no other
way of getting your attention other than
making you feel bad making you feel
shame guilt anxiety depression that's
how your conscious knocks on your door
and says dude you're living in
congruently with how you believe you
should be living and that's why I'm
giving you negative thoughts and
negative voices in your head just
literally flip the switch and tomorrow
live congruently to the man you want to
live be don't hit the snooze button
maybe you're sick and tired of hitting
the snooze button drink your 30 ounces
of water like Sean Stevenson says right
first thing in the morning I don't even
know why he said that I just love the
guy so much I read that in his book like
10 years ago and I just drink 30 ounces
of water every single morning it doesn't
do it doesn't do me any harm only does
me good I send out my three gratitude
text messages because I wake up angry
and bitter most days because that's
factory installed for me like I know who
I am I'm so self-aware that I have to
send out three gratitude messages every
morning so I can put myself in a state
of gratitude that is what Consciousness
and my conscience demands of me and if I
don't I'll still be the miserable
yeah right so we have to do the thing
that our body wants us to do be
congruent with the man you want to be if
you don't the inner selft talk will
always be
negative yeah the uh keeping promises to
yourself is just this insanely powerful
tactic and what I realized especially
throughout a lot of my 20s was that
the things that I was doing in the story
that I was telling myself about who I
should be weren't aligning right right
that I just I felt like I was built for
more I felt like I should be more
mindful more
equanimous that my memory my the texture
of my existence should have been better
the inner texture not materially right I
never cared for that I I still don't
largely which is what I think makes me a
particularly bad businessman I ran a
business for 15 years didn't really care
it was just a game to me it was never
really about money money was a it's a
fantastic scoreboard but it wasn't about
that I felt like I was built for more
and I knew that I wasn't keeping
promises to myself like I was cheating
on girlfriends and
stuff and the worst part about the way
that I felt after cheating on
girlfriends wasn't me being caught it
was what it told me about the sort of
person that I was that I would have hurt
this completely innocent
other part of my life who done nothing
except for care for me done nothing
except for try and make my life good and
I'd been disloyal and
damaging and I thought right is this
really like who you are is this really
who you want to be and I I didn't and
that was like it was like a
Fugue state for a long time of me
thinking well Jesus Christ like if this
is if this is the person that you say
that you're supposed to be why the hell
are you doing all of these different
things right right and so how did you
feel let's just like let's just take a
moment and unravel that for a moment if
you don't
mind so as you're cheating and as you're
doing things it's harming this person
who otherwise loves you and cares for
you and wants to see you thrive and you
know that that's not the guy that you
are this is not the man that you want to
be the difference between that is how
did you feel what did you
experience it was pain it was a lack it
was a sense of a lack it was
a uh a bitterness turned inward against
my own inaptitude my own weakness my own
fragility uh the fact that I was at the
mercy of my own base instincts I didn't
have the control I didn't have the
Insight I I just was
not I was not all that I could be and
the fact that I knew that there was
potential there was what hurt the most
right yeah the fact that I felt like I
was built for more and
yet I hadn't decided to answer the call
of that uh and I had this I had this
this may resonate with people that kind
of come from a background where they
don't have as many good Role Models
around as they would like and and you
know you don't feel like you fit in and
and struggle to find people that give
you the values that you want uh I had
for a good while a chip on my shoulder
about not being given the tools that
could have got me to the place that I
wanted to go more quickly you mentioned
yourself like I started late I think you
said yeah um you like a a delayed onset
intellectual adolescence perhaps I'm a
late bloomer in every category of Life
man fantastic so I almost had a I had a
resentment toward those people uh to W
the fact that I wasn't given the tools
sufficiently early on uh
and even accepting that even being able
to see that for what it is okay well
look what did you want did you want a
land Boton from the school of life or
Jordan Peterson to be born early like
what the did you want did you want
YouTube to be invented more earlier than
it was it wasn't right like you found
this you found the things that you
needed to find when you were ready to
find them and when they were available
to you and not a moment before right and
yeah it's like um kind of like personal
development uh wistfulness MH you know
that oh if only I'd been given the tools
more early on I could have avoided the
this and the done the
that and I wasn't I giving them when I
was giving them dude that's the thing
too is I'll see so many great human
beings that have a massive amount of
potential and and think about this like
there's the cure for cancer probably
lives in someone's head right now mhm I
mean the potential for the Cure for
cancer exists the potential for many
things for Life on Mars exists but
there's someone who's basically in the
shoes that Chris 1.0 was in which is
they they know they they are meant for
more like you said I felt this gnawing
in my gut I knew I was meant for more I
had a greater calling however I was
living a subpar life and the Gap in
between is self-sabotaging behavior the
Gap in between is limiting beliefs the
Gap in between is kind of hitting this
glass ceiling of success and then
letting yourself slide back down because
you don't believe you're worthy of
Happiness success love whatever the
thing is because you're in
congruent
and at some
point we begin to then go well I'm this
way because Mom and Dad they divorced I
was beaten in my case I was molested as
a child growing up uh then we came to
America and gang bangers started to pick
on me and beat me up and and laugh at me
and call me Foreigner and we can find so
many things to blame and if only like
you said YouTube was created earlier and
and if only I knew what a mentor was I
could have gotten a mentor sooner okay
great at some point you've got to turn
the fingers on yourself and go now
YouTube exists now I'm aware of what
self-help is I know what books to read
are you reading them now are you
changing their narrative now or are you
still blaming mom and dad and the school
system and whatever happened to us as a
kid cuz if you are you're living in the
past and I don't know any anyone that's
gotten any decent quality of life moving
forward when they're constantly looking
in the rearview mirror mhm well what's
the Salve to this you know it's all well
and good for uh largely two people who
have been through setfire and zero to
one is the biggest step right yeah it is
the most difficult one yeah um because
you need momentum precisely yes uh you
work with guys a lot I'm going to guess
that most of the guys that you'll deal
with at least are probably not at zero
but many will be beginning on the
journey and there'll be a little bit of
momentum behind them yeah with the guys
that you work
with what are the things that are most
common that they need to overcome in
order to be able to retell that story
and improve those beliefs
internally I think the most common thing
that we see in the guys that we work
with at the project specifically and
these are guys like you said they're not
starting at zero they have some momentum
they they might have a business that's
doing a few hundred thousand a year or
maybe a few million a year uh but they
realize they're still meant for more and
it doesn't matter what they're doing
because we've got guys that were you
know senators and guys that are like
professional poker players who who are
doing fantastically well financially but
if finan if the finances were the only
measuring stick then great they're
successful hey go on Elon musk's the
number one on the planet right y he'd be
exactly but it's not the only measuring
stick because these are the guys who are
also sabotaging their life one
particular guy I can tell you that he he
was making about 20 million a year and
he's the second in commands of chief
operations officer for a company in I'll
use a different city let's
say oh I don't know Camaro Beach but he
would drive from Los Angeles to Camaro
Beach three times a week to work at the
corporate office the rest of the time
he'd work from home doing really well
for himself however he would on his way
home he would stop at one mistress's
house and then another mistress's house
and then at Commerce Casino to gamble
and then he'd come home and it's because
he felt he was Unworthy of earning that
and he was just constantly
self-sabotaging to destroy all that as
we started to dig deeper it's typically
some kind of event that took place that
changed their trajectory on how they
felt about themselves the event could
have been they were drinking and driving
crossed an intersection killed a family
of four in the car they survived they
have survivors guilt it could be that
they were physically mentally
emotionally sexually abused and they
haven't reconciled with that so that
soundtrack of Shame rage confusion is
constantly playing in the background as
you're trying to develop a career get
into a marriage raise your children
start a business partnership you're
doing all that with this almost like
this 55 kilogram kettle bell attached to
you so if we're going to race and I'm
like hey Chris before you race I'm just
going to chain this kettle bell to your
leg you're always going to have an
unfair a disadvantage right and so if we
can just go back and identify because as
men we're really good at
compartmentalizing and going
everything's good everything's good yeah
that happened to me but everything's
good no it's not man it's like a
corrupted hard drive your hard drivve is
corrupted and when you're pushing this
button there's a delayed response or you
push the button a but you get the letter
S on the word doc and you're like what
the is going on it's a corrupted
system and so if we can go back and
identify what happened that created
these toxic cognitions these false
beliefs and narratives about yourself
solve through
it now you can actually go and say this
is actually not my story therefore
that's not my identity this is my new
identity I'm a badass husband I
could be a badass father I could be a
badass friend and then you'll start
looking for evidence in that you'll
start taking on the actions and deeds
and habits and characteristics of a
badass dude but you have to first
address that and without addressing that
in other words without
apologizing you're never going to have
you know if let's go back to that
relationship that you had where you
cheated on this on this on this
woman if you went back and apologize to
her it would be just as meaningful to
her as it would be for you in terms of
closure and healing then you would go
you know what that's what a higher
status man does that's what a dude who's
connected to Consciousness does he owns
what he hey I'm sorry for doing this I
imagine it made you feel this way here's
what I can do to make it right if that's
okay with you like that's a proper
apology whether she accepts it or not
doesn't matter you did the deed now you
can move forward with Grace and so by
not fixing the traumas that and no one
it's rare like one out of every three
people have been physically or mentally
abused one out of every four have been
sexually abused so if we just look at
the number of dudes in this building
like there's trauma all around
us right so we got to do the work heal
from it move on with the new identity
you're someone who had some pretty
ruthless trauma growing up as a kid that
is used
used many people feel like experiences
that were outside of their control hold
back their potential when they're moving
forward what has your worldview been of
this you know patient zero for having
dealt with something bad and then come
out the other side of it like what do
you say to people that have had things
bad happen in their past yeah well we we
don't we don't realize that that bad
thing when healed through or processed
through could actually become a
superpower right and so I'll give you an
example I was molested by two older Boys
in Armenia over and over again between
the ages of four and six when I turned
six years old my dad decided we're going
to escape the Soviet Union he was a
member of the Communist Party he decided
we're going to escape um what he doesn't
realize is by escaping and bringing us
to the United States he saved me from
almost daily molestation by these two
older boys you think that that would
have just continued I would imagine so
until I got older and stood up for
myself right uh but I was you know
between four and 6 years old these guys
were like 12 13 14 years old and so I
come to the United States I've never
told anyone about this I grow up I get
married I have kids all the way until 38
years old until I have this massive
panic attack right which I thought was
unrelated to that I never once I just
thought hey that's behind me now I've
left that I go work with the therapist
and I'm like hey man I had a panic
attack they put me on Xanax I don't want
to be on Xanax the doctor said I should
do talk therapy I think talk therapy is
for broken people I'm clearly not broken
so me right right me yeah not this one
and he goes well I think I within four
or five sessions I can help you give you
some tools to cope with your anxiety I
was like great and being a very typ a
high-speed tightly wound person I told
him I said I don't want this to be an
indefinite thing where I'm sitting on
your couch like how long would it take
he says three to four five sessions Max
great so he teaches me a few things like
you know action alleviates anxiety and
anxiety being anticipation of future
pain and halt when you're hungry angry
lonely tired uh you're more likely to go
back to your old ways like if you're an
alcoholic and you're hungry lonely angry
tired you're more likely to hit the
bottle or whatever so just manage your
Halt and understand that action
alleviates anxiety and anxiety is really
anticipation of future pain and get your
sleep and don't try and burn the candle
on both ends all common sense
right and so you know four or five weeks
ago by him like his name is Kevin I go
Kevin I feel like a million bucks like I
don't even have
this there to be this this little
undertone of anxiousness constantly
nying at me after about two or three
weeks with him gone right gone I'm
sleeping like a champ so I'm shaking his
hand writing signing with a credit card
statement and I'm standing at his
door um and he goes hey can I just ask
you one question how's how's your
relationship with your parents like do
you want to talk about that maybe and I
realize now maybe he was trying to
obviously not lose a patient not lose a
client right at the end of the day the
man's running a
business um at least that's my
assumption I should call him an ask him
I can't make that assumption for
agreements right for agreement says
don't go assuming things
so I was like a my parents like look
dude I come from a communist country my
dad was a little
heavy-handed he slapped me around here
and there but quite honestly that was
nothing compared to what happened to me
in Armenia I had never not even told my
wife about what happened to me in
Armenia but in these five sessions Kevin
had built such rapport with me that I
felt like I could throw that out there
and he goes well what happened and I
just start balling and I'm crying and
I'm just like snots coming out my nose
and he's asking me questions and I could
just nod my head yes or no you know were
you raped and I'm shaking my head no
were you were you abused yes were you
molested yes you know by a babysitter no
and so finally we get I can blurred out
by two older boys right and he goes
bedus I'm so sorry and I said Kevin
don't be what happened to that little
boy I've dealt with and he goes can you
say what happened to me I've healed from
and I went to a new level of crime bro
I'm standing Chris I'm standing so it's
a two-story building I'm standing at his
door I've handed him the credit card
slip and I'm thinking what's faster
smashing my way through the glass and
just Falling Towards my car or going
down the staircase like that's all my
brain is thinking I've gone fully human
animal right I've gone limic just Escape
I just want to leave this conversation
right but I'm stuck also my body has
seized yeah and as I calm down and he
hands me a napkin I drink some water he
goes bados can I tell you something I
said sure he said um you
know by saying what happened to that
little boy that's called disassociation
I'd never even heard that term this is
10 11 years ago he goes that's the first
step in developing a multiple
personality disorder I'm like holy
it's the last thing I need right
so I spent the next 15 months on his
couch every Monday so he did retain it
patient but man we dug deep and what we
found is I was living with shame rage
confusion shame like I I was embarrassed
that my friend Chris can't fig find out
about this he's going to think I'm
broken I'm I'm filthy I'm dirty like why
would you let two older boys do that
because at the end of the day I let them
do that to me and Kevin helped me unpack
that that you know young boys look up to
their dads their older brothers the
older boys in the community is the right
of passage and these boys took advantage
of that abused that right exactly right
and then the confusion like am I gay am
I gay so I went around banging
millions of chicks in my 20s bro to to
sub signal to yourself yes yeah and you
know what Kevin said so so I was like
Kevin like what the man so was I
gay he goes well you know did you read
any gay porn magazines or anything I'm
like no he's like well clearly not did
you go and seek out any gay sex I go no
clearly not and I realized like instead
I went and just ran
through hundreds of women just to signal
to myself that I'm not right like that's
how stupid I was but again when you're
limic you're just looking for a solution
and then the rage how come no one
protected me in Armenia there's the
babushkas the the
grandmas in Russian Babushka means
grandma and Armenia was under Russian
Soviet control and these grandmas are
like the Mafia bro they like
oversee all the children doesn't matter
if it's their grandchild or not not they
would make me wash my hands and clean my
face Etc yet they wouldn't save me from
what happened there and I realized with
Kevin's help they never saw that they
would have torn those boys limb limb to
limb had they seen what those boys were
doing and so what really happened is on
my timeline of life there's this giant
Mountain that I didn't want anyone to
see so it's like hey all no one see
what's going on here shame rage
confusion unworthiness unlovable I even
remember telling my wife one time I go
you and andw and Chloe metaphorically
are in this room then there's this
hallway and I'm in the hallway and
that's as close as I can get to you guys
right and she started balling like
that's so sad she goes I feel that like
I feel like there's another layer I have
to break through to get to you but I was
constantly protecting myself from
everybody and so 15 months of working
with Kevin that Giant mountain on my
timeline of life was just a little speed
bump no different than the time I tore
my bicep or the time I
gotone into a car
accident that's what we need to do to be
able to break those glass ceilings and
be able to actually become the version
of ourselves that we're called to be
what was the time that you told your
wife about you you know you've bowled in
front of Kevin yeah but how long did it
take after speaking to him before you
were able to open up to your wife about
it probably about four or five months in
Kevin had me write a letter to my
younger self okay and he gave me the
first sentence of that letter which was
uh dear
bados um between the ages of four and
six you were molested by two older boys
but today dot dot dot as in today you're
this guy and that guy and you've done
this and right like in other words let's
go find evidence that you're not broken
unworthy shameful confused angry and so
I wrote a 11-page letter Kevin and I
broke that down sentence by sentence and
I just felt like dude I could I can go
to my wife and talk about this and so I
did and it was very matter of fact and
you know she was emotional about it
right as you can imagine cuz here I was
going through it with Kevin for months
and now I'm springing this on her
several years into our marriage so she
was emotional about it but she also
understood she hugged me she goes I love
you nothing changes and I was like in my
head I'm like really like you don't
think I'm gross right like that's still
that voice still exists M months later
Joe polish asks me to speak at his
genius Network event and the guy
speaking before me was Tony Robbins and
he's up on stage talking about you know
as humans we're supposed to be built for
the winter and not for the summer and be
prepared Winter's coming and his like
his closing line he's you know smacking
his big giant Mitten hands together and
pumping everybody up and I'm nervous as
getting miked up in the back like
how do you follow this guy I
supposed to talk about leadership cuz
you know Fit Body B Camp had grown
pretty big big International franchise
and I'm the leader of it but I realized
Joe poish told me there's 350 attendees
at this event and all of them are just
multi-
multi-millionaires and they don't
necessarily have to be great leaders you
can just hire a great leader at that
point right all this to say that I get
up on stage I'm like Kevin or uh Joe I
know I'm supposed to talk about
leadership and how I built Fit Body Boot
Camp through great leadership but I
really want to talk about something else
I want to talk about how I was molested
as a kid between the of four and six and
how that limited my growth not only in
business but in relationship in my
friendships Etc and I could see grown
men squirming in their seats looking
towards the exit and dude that
conversation that I had with that
audience if you had asked me a couple
years earlier would you ever stand in
front of an audience and talk about how
you were molested and how it how it
showed up and what it did to you and
then how you healed from it so I think
this is what I going back to what I was
saying it was my greatest superpower
because now I can stand in front of
thousands of people and share this
message on this podcast from a stage on
my show and grown ass man will be like
dude you went through that too I did as
well and I'm telling you like dudes with
blue check marks with millions of
followings they they'll see me backstage
in a green room and hug me and we'll
start
crying I think I was supposed that it
sounds morbid but that was supposed to
have happened to me and I was supposed
to have healed and it was supposed to
have become my superpower to have
compassion and empathy for men and which
is why I work with so many men in
healing them in so many ways and just
actually give showing them the path to
heal I don't heal anyone you
heal yourself you have everything you
need to heal yourself does that make
sense yeah dude it's very interesting to
think about how the things that we're
most proud of in ourselves are the light
side of something dark that we are often
ashamed of or resentful about or bitter
uh I often talk about
how I was pretty unpopular as a kid only
child a lot of time in solitude but the
light side of that is that I never
needed anybody's permission to go and do
anything right right because I never had
anybody's permission before I'm happily
able to go and outw work on my own drop
me on a desert island I'll find a laptop
and start working on it you know like
there will
be it's a it's a superpower and and
being able to move to another country
you know my the joy that I get from from
traveling the joy that I get from
connecting with other people we talked
earlier on about like obsessive
observing which is another skill that I
developed because I didn't understand
why other kids had friends and I didn't
so I observed obsessively about the way
they tied their tie or the way that they
walked or the type of shoes that they
had or the shoulder that They Carried
their bag on and that was the reason
that they had friends and I
didn't but Downstream from that is
something that I really value
myself the point that I feel
the thing that I really kind of want
people to take away is
that it is unfortunately a a
double-edged sword and if you do not do
some work to ameliorate those things and
to work out how the skills that you've
developed or your response to the things
that you don't like in yourself can be
used to make the texture of your own
existence better if you don't go and do
that you will continue to be ruled by
things that you hate agreed
and
the like how close you can come to
having that happen is terrifying
yeah yeah yeah it's really really scary
like I see I can see the other path or
many other paths right there's many many
many ways there's many many sets of SL
slippery slides down into some circle of
hell and there's only a couple of set of
stairs up yeah and uh yeah I you know I
wish I wish I could give people the hope
that they can that they can do that that
they can make that happen well see but
but that's what we're doing here it's
it's those who
leave make excuses that well you know it
seems like you were had this obsessive
observing ability that I don't or you
guys have this ability to focus and have
Singularity of focus on a task and I
don't well I didn't I when we came to
America by by second grade the Anaheim
Union High School District or Anheim
School District uh decided to do I don't
know studies on all the Immigrant kids
in that particular School Walt Disney
Elementary and they figured out that I'm
OCD and
add right and this is before the uh
perhaps over yeah pathological iation of
exactly this was we're talking 84 85
1984 1985 and so they put me on riddle
in different doses trying to figure out
what's going to work and I remember just
slumping over just being hyper uh but
because of that they put me in these
classes for special education right
special ed classes and so effectively I
was in classes with what they called
retards back then right and so that
became part of my identity that
obviously I'm slow obviously I'm I'm not
capable um when in reality that too was
a superpower my ability to obsess about
something that interests me is a
superpower and so the people who might
be like well you got I don't have this
and I don't have that it's like but what
you do have if you heal through it and
weaponize it and that's what we need to
do I weaponized add I weaponized OCD I
weaponized being molested I weaponized
being called a foreigner an immigrant
getting a chip on my shoulder so
big that I was like no one ever will put
my family in a financially destitute
place man ever ever and so to me making
an obscene amount of money was like this
Mission and that led to then developing
you know as a human even more I think I
had to solve through that first because
money was a big factor as an immigrant
in this country when you're living in
Section 8 housing but you can weaponize
anything that's happened to you so they
don't have to have the gift that you
have or I have you just have to
understand that what's happened to you
if you can heal through it solve through
it process through it there's a massive
superpower on the other side
it's the work the majority are not
willing to do but wanting the outcome
that we have and that's again once again
the Gap and it's the Gap that makes them
feel a certain way about life they hate
life and they they think they're at a
disadvantage and they're anxious about
it so then they begin to escape and
soothe with drugs and alcohol infidelity
pornography gambling whatever the source
is and I don't care I can check off
every box I can check off every
one of those boxes but if you do the
work and you close that Gap and time
collapse you will have that superpower
and you can start living the life you're
meant to live we'll get back to talking
to bed Ross in one minute but first I
need to tell you about surf Shar if you
want to protect your browsing online and
and get access to the entire world's
Netflix library for less than the price
of a cup of coffee per month you should
be using surf shark VPN you can browse
the internet without the VPN but it's
kind of like trying to run a marathon in
Crocs you can do it but it's going to be
dangerous and uncomfortable if you use
public Wi-Fi networks like a library or
a cafeteria or an airport the internet
admin of that Network can see all of the
traffic going back and forth between
your computer and the internet and that
is trees bad all of this is fixed by
using surf shark it takes two clicks of
a button it is available across
unlimited devices your laptop your phone
your iPad even your smart TV while I'm
over here in America maybe I want to
access some British Netflix just turn on
surf shark VPN and I immediately get
access to all of that you can get an 83%
discount plus 3 months free and a 30-day
money back guarantee by going to the
link in the description below or heading
to Surf shark. deod wisdom that's surf
shark. deals slod wisdom I've heard you
say if you're going to eat get good
at it yeah what do you mean when you say
that well look
now life is not going to be butterflies
and flowers and rose gardens all the
time in building a massive brand like
Fit Body Boot Camp I had to eat a lot of
with the Federal Trade Commission
you know I started Fit Body Boot Camp
and I wanted to uh make sure that all of
my lienes at the time had a protected
territory because you know CrossFit for
example you can open up a CrossFit cross
the street from another CrossFit and
they just have to compete so my whole
thing was if I have this licensing
program I can give them a 5m protected
territory they're going to be cool with
each other right little did I know that
by doing that one thing I crossed the
line into franchising the great state of
California decided they're going to find
me
$2500 times 115 locations that I had and
I said if you guys did that I'm going to
have to go bankrupt and those 115
locations are going to have to fend for
themselves right they've opened up
location they' bought equipment they're
running their business we coaching them
in making this thing successful so I've
had to eat a lot of I was having
to I was having to negotiate with the
state of California all while trying to
also find ways to refinance my house and
get another credit card so that if I had
to pay that money 115 locations times
$2,500 I would thankfully the state of
California was kind enough to say don't
pay us the money however don't sell
another location until tell you become a
franchise so again more eating it
cost me
$887,000 to become a franchise you got
to get a fa franchise agreement FDD
there's 13 states that require different
fdds franchise disclosure documents then
you're overseen by the Federal Trade
Commission you go to three audits a year
you have to have your uh uh operations
manual made in a very specific way it
doesn't matter if you're a Subway
sandwiches Jiffy Lube or a Fit Body Boot
Camp this is how it is and the
disclosures have to be very specific
this is all new to me bro I'm
like barely getting bu back in 2010 but
all of a sudden by 2012 I have to become
a franchise I got good at eating
very effectively and efficiently because
if I'm going to eat it slow it's just
going to prolong the pain so if I'm
going to go into franchising or if I
have to negotiate with with the state of
California if I have to do anything the
pandemic for example we lost 218
locations fit by boot camp locations
from March 16th to December 31st of 2020
so I decided all right well if we're
going to eat we're going to eat it
really fast and get really good at it so
let's just make a full pivot into online
coaching like take all your personal
training clients boot camp clients put
them in on Facebook groups we're going
to use trainer eyes we're going to
follow along workouts the problem is
most people they will sit on this in
this dissatisfaction and stay there and
stew in it and root in it my whole thing
is dude you're you're giving
sandwiches eat them as quickly as you
can and move on like you have to move on
my friend Jason Redmond he's a uh
retired Navy SEAL was shot up all over
his face Purple Heart recipient uh he
says you know he was on a mission and
they found themselves on the X right
like you he's the Predator him and his
team and they're going to kill the bad
guys who are bomb makers this is in Iraq
in
2007 and next thing you
know they get ambushed and he gets shot
up seven shots across the body one hits
him through the cheek bone blows out his
orbital plate um his eyeballs is hanging
his nose is gone um shoots him in the
arm uh he almost had to get his arm
amput amputated he found himself on the
X that night him and his team so now at
this point should they just sit there
and call for an air strike and wait or
do they just do what they can and shoot
back and attack and attack and attack
and so what he says in his book is that
they had to just fullon attack these
guys while calling in an air strike that
was danger close to Jason Redmond he
caught shrapnel but the bad guys were
dead hel opter came in saved his ass but
the bottom line is like you most humans
will find themselves on an X of Ambush
life will Ambush you and they sit in it
they root in it they take forever to
Stew in it instead eat it quickly and
move on does that make sense
yeah I what uh what it meant to me if
you're going to eat get good at it
was in order to achieve anything that
you care about there is going to be an
Associated amount of that you need
to eat
if you want to take on the burden of
trying to achieve something in life
which is Meaningful to you accept that
the eating is not a bug it is a
feature fact it is a part and parcel of
existing and trying to locally reverse
entropy right I'm locally reversing it
it is trying to act on me you're a
finite creature with an infinite
complexity around you of course you're
going to be scared there are literally
an unlimited number of ways that you can
die and a very very small number that
you can live through right like that's
just on a macro level but when it comes
to achieving a life where the outcome is
the one that you wanted like that's one
outcome and yeah there's a few
different Roots there but like it's a
you know the entirety of different I
could walk outside now put like put my
head on the t i and get HD by a truck or
I could put my head slightly to the left
of it like all of these different
iterations right the Multiverse of ways
that Chris's demise could occur
to
her and yet you believe you hope that
you can manage to
Wrangle reality Your Existence into some
sort of usable functional useful nice
enjoyable
form there is going to be an Associated
amount of pain and eating that goes
along with it MH and I do believe that's
a function of our creator right whether
you believe in universe I Consciousness
you believe a god you believe that
whatever I believe we have to go through
a series of tests to see if we are
qualified to the for the next level of
Happiness Bliss Joy success abundance
whatever and so the sandwiches will
be laid out along your journey there is
no way to circumvent that the Creator
does want to test you and I believe
proof of that is what do they say 82% of
lottery winners are back to being broke
within two and a half years well that's
because they didn't eat the
sandwiches they didn't deal with the
adversity the pain the setbacks and so
they don't know how to value that wealth
and therefore they lose it a fool and
his money will quickly be parted and I'm
not even Christian it's just the Jesus
wrote something that really made sense
and so if we know that we have to eat
those sandwiches one get really
good at it and two understand that it's
part of the process so that you can
achieve the outcome that's
desired 80% of the time you'll feel like
you're failing 15% of the time you'll
feel like you're treading water 4% of
the time you'll feel like it's over 1%
of the time you'll feel like you're
winning why yeah this is this is not
scientific by the way this is something
that I would just share with my wife
stand Journal Bro Science yeah exactly
this is just Bro Science but based off
20 years as an
entrepreneur that's about how I felt 80%
of the time I felt like I was just
behind I was constantly behind you know
and and but that 1% of the time I felt
like I was winning and then after a few
years about five six years into my
career as an entrepreneur I realized the
secret is just to find as many of these
1% and keep keep stacking them yeah cuz
I could dwell on the 80% of the time
where I feel behind or the or the
freaking whatever it was 5 10% that I
feel like you know everything's falling
apart around me like the 4% that
everything's falling apart around me or
I could just focus on these 1centers and
realize that okay that's a win let's
move on to the next battle the next
battle next Battle Before You Know
You've Won the War you know Inc 500 uh
recognition entrepreneur magazines top
200 franchises those recognitions will
come if you stack to 1centers you don't
need 100% wins and I think it's probably
impossible to have 100% wins all the
time uh but as as any kind of high
performer and I believe this this is
probably true for professional sports uh
for people who are actors and
celebrities they they feel like they're
just behind they're not doing it they
someone else got the part and then boom
they land a part that gets them the
Oscar that's a 1center stack more of
those and that's what worked for me I
put this in a newsletter the other week
so I want to teach you about it I think
it's kind of related to what we're
talking about here I've been thinking
about how to achieve a realistic path to
Enlightenment as much as moving to a
cave in the woods and spending a decade
in silent Retreat might be great for
your spirit it's not going to be doable
by pretty much anyone if you've
meditated enough you know that you
accumulate momentum in mindfulness kind
of like a swell moving underwater after
enough time there is a force and a power
to your ability to drop into the present
moment moment and sometimes even little
waves of genuine calm Insight break
above the surface but if you're anything
like me it doesn't result in an extended
self-perpetuating Enlightenment doesn't
even really work on its own where your
mindfulness sneaks up on you and you're
in the present moment without realizing
it more so consistent meditation and a
focus on mindfulness strengthens the
thinking muscle that you use to Wrangle
your mind to actually exist in the now
you learn to punctuate your day with
instances where your mind finally
settles into the moment and then it's
gone
but then you can get it back later in
the day and as far as I can tell this is
the realistic path to Enlightenment you
are never going to become a fully Bliss
Out In Perpetual non-dual astral realm
synchronicity bro but you can string
together a few moments of Peace So that
at least for a few times each day your
mind rests where your feet are I always
used to think that this was a failure if
I can achieve mindfulness but then lose
it that's still not persistent
Enlightenment so I failed instead I
think it's smart to reframe the goal if
you can just have your mind and your
feet in the same location 5 or 10 or 20
times a day that's a good start and then
maybe you can do it 25 or 30 times that
seems both attainable and really
useful and that seems to be what you
were doing there right I understand that
self-doubt and uncertainty and fear of
the future is just going to riddle my
experience as I try and do something
that's difficult that was in the
business world but it could be in
personal development it could be in
trying to reshape the dynamic of your
family or whatever it is that you're
trying to do and presuming that you're
going to be able to do this and it's
just like an ambient peace equanimous
beautiful like membrane that you get to
skate along that's not going to happen
but what you can do is try and string
together a series of these winds yeah
here is a land mark that I have gotten
to and importantly string together a
series of wins that you don't
immediately look over the shoulder of as
soon as it's happened oh ink 500
fantastic but what's next it's like no
no no no no like allow yourself to
celebrate yeah I think uh hardwiring
Happiness by Rick Hansen's a really
great book that it came out just a
little bit before the podcast Revolution
which is a shame because I think it
would have really changed a lot of
people he came on the show to talk about
a second book five years ago what he
basically says is that when good things
happen you should allow yourself to
marinade in them as much as possible
even if it's just a small thing and this
is such an unbelievable tactic like
having a 10-minute walk after after
having food something good happens your
first response should not be to kind of
accept it for what it is you know people
that hold themselves to high standards I
do this too there's almost a part of me
that doesn't want to bathe in things
that go well because they should be a
given because I'm a high performer that
Demands a lot of myself get you know
what I mean I do yeah so I do but this
isn't the way that the the brain we
spoke about the reticular AC activating
System earlier on you want to
permanently be on the lookout for as
many reasons to feel good about yourself
as possible because Lord knows
there's enough reasons to feel like
about yourself right and everybody has
that yeah so what I try to do and I fail
a lot and I need to work harder at this
specific skill maybe do a Sprint for
sort of three months where I really
really really focus on it I finish a
podcast I finish a podcast like three or
four times a week like I have the
opportunity to set myself a little
reminder maybe I need to post- it not
to set myself a little reminder that
when I finish for just you know 15 or 30
seconds after I do that or after you
complete the tasks that you said for the
day or finish your gym routine or or uh
do your meditation or have a great
conversation with your partner or have a
bad conversation with someone that you
didn't want to but you did because you
needed to be truthful and be virtuous to
yourself when you do that just allow it
to sit for 30 seconds and just marinade
in the sensation of that yeah
okay how does it feel for me to have
done something that I feel proud and
satisfied about myself for doing and
Rick neurons that fight together why
together you will continue to find
reasons to feel good about yourself yeah
and uh as a strategy you know that
that's it that's the concept of
hardwiring Happiness there in the book
like highly recommend you go and read it
but if you don't want to there's there's
the concept what what you're describing
there especially for high performers
right PE people that are highp speed
tightly wound and have high expectations
of themselves
we are wired to
get to get
satisfaction to get selfworth through
production
production which in many ways I'm
jealous of regular people who can just
watch TV and you know not feel lazy and
sluggish dude I could watch TV like a
show with my son like I we I we watched
Pulp Fiction the other day and I had
complet I probably stack like 15 20 wins
that day but after watching Pulp Fiction
it's somewhat of a long movie I was like
man this was not productive like I
have conditioned myself or maybe better
said this
way I've been wired through a series of
abuse and Trauma and neglect to feel
that I am only a worthy human when I am
producing and if I am producing I'm
worthy and so when I'm relaxing if I'm
sick if I'm watching TV I'm not
and therefore we have guilt and
therefore we don't allow ourselves to
enjoy for even 15 seconds that win
because I must go on and produce again
because that's the only way I'm a worthy
human it it doesn't work that way though
like I've I am I am absolutely patient
zero for what you are talking about I
attached my sense of selfworth for a
decade and a half to the success of the
events I I ran nightlife
uh business for a very long time uh I
came up with uh something that I think
is kind of related to this I need a
fourth Horseman I'm doing it for a a
project I'm working on at the moment uh
I've got three horses of the
productivity apocalypse so far I'm going
to find a fourth one or I'm just going
to have to retrofit three horses of the
productivity apocalypse so um
productivity Purgatory is the first one
and this is really interesting
so if you attach a lot of your sense of
selfworth to being productive what you
can end up doing is even having
rejuvenative relaxation protocols only
existing because you believe that they
will facilitate your productivity
tomorrow so you don't go for a walk with
your partner in nature because you want
to enjoy their time it's because you
listen to an Andrew huberman episode
that said 15 minutes of walking down
regulates your amigdala so that your
focus response and dopaminergic seaa is
better tomorrow right it allows you to
never Escape productivity which is
productivity Purgatory the dark
playground is the second one this is an
idea from Tim Urban and this is almost
kind of the opposite so the dark
playground is when you are trying to to
be productive you should be being
productive but you're choosing to do
something which is unproductive so
you're uh procrastinating off from
productivity to watch YouTube or or read
a book or scroll Tik Tok or whatever you
don't get the
enjoyment of the entertainment because
you've got the guilt of not being
productive and obviously you don't get
the outcome of the productivity because
you're not being productive sure so
that's a dark playground and then not
being able to enjoy fun because you feel
like you should be working is the third
one and haven't come up with a meme for
that yet you've caught me partway
through it's like I've only got my pants
on I haven't fully dressed yet um but
yeah not being able to enjoy fun because
you feel like you should be working
which is the one that you just
identified there and look being a sort
of a type A Hard charging person comes
with its benefits but again as we talked
about before you know like the
true third wve renaissance man is the
guy who is also able to go to the SE
shells for a week with his partner not
work switch off his phone and know that
all of the like what was the reason for
working this hard if you cannot let it
go Bingo that is a really difficult
question for lots of people to answer
and ultimately what it comes down to is
it is a cope to bolster their sense of
worthiness to the world I am only worthy
when I train for this hard every single
morning do the achieve this much earn
this much money answer this many emails
only get this much sleep that's a
difficult one when people see
their restriction of things that are
good for them are enjoyable as a badge
of honor somehow and uh yeah I think
that we should all be very very cautious
of taking what is absolutely a
performance enhan you know your ability
to or your your discomfort around
relaxation drives you to do more things
but in no one's world is that
optimal yeah right that's not what you
want like what's the reason for working
this hard if you are unable to enjoy the
fruits of your labor you know so
interestingly enough what ended up
helping me and again remember my the
work I did with Kevin Downing my
therapist was 10 and a half 11 years
ago and then as I started spending so
healing helped me because I realized my
selfworth is not directly attached to
production right so always goes back to
Healing healing cuz again you're given
trauma either accidentally because you
know the family gives you a nickname
that you attach some kind of weird
meaning to and that you carry that for
decades into your future or true trauma
happened like you were raped molested
abused whatever U however the trauma
shows up healing is necessary otherwise
your self-worth is going to be attached
to something either either attached to
you being attached to someone or um you
always being the Martyr or production in
my case our case especially when you're
heart charger but as I healed I realized
myself for is not attached to that one
bit and so I can catch the conversation
in my head cuz literally as Andrew and I
were watching Pulp Fiction and I'm like
man this movie's going along pretty long
here um I don't feel that productive I'm
like dude I'm having the greatest time
with my son right now immediately I can
catch that negative thought that still
because here's the deal I think you've
been around long enough to know when you
know Microsoft it would have a like your
Microsoft uh based computer would have a
virus sometimes it wouldn't be able to
necessarily fix or get rid of the virus
it would quarantine the virus remember
that quarantine the virus on your hard
drive so the virus I think gets
quarantined in US it doesn't go away
it's quarantined MH and so while I know
my self worth now is not attached to
production it will still rear its ugly
head that's the realistic path to
Enlightenment again right self awareness
yeah it's it's look your day is going to
be punctuated with Reflections that upon
reflection you're going to wish you
didn't have yeah it's not the job of you
to seamlessly perfectly thread the
needle through this mindfield of
potential thought failures your job is
to be able to notice them when they
arise like the perfect meditation
session is not the one where your mind
never gets distracted it's when you
notice when it does MHM exactly and this
is the same you sit down and you notice
this little habit arise you know like
taipe bed Ross just ambiently
appears hey hey you could be working hey
there's emails to answer hey you could
be doing you could be being more
productive okay I see I see that I see
that and that maybe even some truth to
it and we release and allow that to go
right like that's and that is the beauty
of transcending from Human Animal to
human being connecting with
Consciousness because you become the
observer in your life right and you know
this and when you become the Observer
you can now see things almost from
a outside eyes
and I could see from outside eyes like
oh okay that person said something it
rubbed me the wrong way I'm feeling a
certain way human animal wants to react
human being is going to take a moment
and go did he really mean it that way or
is this just triggering something old in
me that's been quarantined yeah and and
when we can have outside eyes and become
the observer in our own life
versus reacting to everything as though
it's factual we begin to get the utmost
amount of control like true control of
our life of our status of our well-being
of our health of our relationships and I
I think you're either going to have some
false sense of control as we talked
about in the beginning where you know
you string some weird things together
just to meet a narrative that you've
built in your mind to give you some
sense of false control or you can have
true control by being The Observer and
realizing hey I'm looking to react I
didn't sleep well last night and this
guide said something that Tri triggered
something in my head for many years ago
and so I'm not going to respond to this
this guy right now um being The Observer
is necessary and to become the Observer
you have to transcend healing
Transcendence that is the ultimate
purpose self-mastery that we have to
achieve in life and I think most are too
distracted by social media and all
content overload to even pause to begin
to listen to the conversation in their
head to see where it's going we'll get
back to talking to bed Ross in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about mudwater mudwater is a coffee
alternative that tastes like cow and
chai had a beautiful baby together it's
got four functional mushrooms with only
a fraction of the caffeine as a cup of
coffee that gives you all of the energy
without the Jitters or crash each
ingredient was added for a specific
purpose cacao and chai for a hint of
caffeine and chocolate-like flavor Lion
Man for Focus ceps to promote Natural
Energy and both chaga and Rishi to help
support a healthy immune system plus
it's Whole 30 approved 100% USDA organic
non-mo vegan and kosher certified lots
of people still want to enjoy a
beautiful hot beverage on the morning
and it is getting into winter time so if
you want to have a hot drink without the
Jitters and crash of coffee this is
where to start right now you can get a
$20 discount plus a free sample of Crea
and a free froth by following the link
in the description below or going to
mwr.com
mowis that's mudw tr.com
slod wisdom yeah I I have a lot of faith
in uh people's ability for personal
growth uh especially this the the people
that are listening to this are already
outliers right they've got enough time
to listen to me and you waffle on about
the nuances of of like
mindfulness for two hours so they're
already outliers but I have a lot of
faith that most people realize that
there's something up here I I'm built
for more I'm built for more and I I I
could become more and I really really
want the tools to be able to do it and
the satisfaction that I get I would
actually go as far as to say that the
satisfaction of noticing when I nearly
go ay and then bring myself back in is
about on par with reflecting and
realizing that I never went to Ry in the
first place because both of those things
have been arrived at by conscious effort
right um being able to sit down and do a
podcast and at no point have even had a
sense of time because I've just been
dialed on the person that I'm sat
opposite is perfect but being distracted
during and realizing oh we've got
to make sure that the flights for that
thing and then going nope and coming
back in is also a win right it's
impossible to lose the only time that
you lose is when you allow that thing to
continue to take you away even if it
does and then you bring yourself back in
and it's strategic lesson it's the John
kavar thing right you either win or you
learn right exactly you've got a quote
that I absolutely adore your haters are
out there holding their breath waiting
for you to fail make sure they suffocate
mhm yeah one thing that I'm cautious of
with that and it's a don't get me wrong
it is a very uh useful frame right use
what you have have including your
resentment over the people that don't
like you and want to see you fail one
thing that I'm slightly cautious of with
that is creating external uh
enemies
that you give too much power to that you
then begin not being a sovereign agent
you then start to play games that other
people want you to play I spoke about
this to uh hosi a few months ago and it
was the first time I'd really been able
to put it into words I'll try and
explain to you and see if it relates to
this
so sometimes in my more juvenile bitter
resentful
moments I try or I imagine I fantasize
about beating
people at their
game because I know that it's a game
that I could win at too let's say that
there's someone who I who has a
particular dislike for me or has some
sort of disdain uh and I know that they
really care about money
and I think well you know I could
dedicate the next 12 months to like
earning more than 10 times your net
worth and I know that that would make
them feel bad and first off it's a
stupid thing to do to let somebody else
determine your game but what Alex taught
me
was even if you win you still
lose because they got you to change your
game your game changed and they didn't
even know that you were playing yeah
and I think that that's I there needs to
be a name for what that is it's like
goal hijack right where you do something
to try and prove a point to somebody
that didn't even know that you were
doing it because of them you consider it
a kind of win because you did
win but you hijacked your own goal to
prove to somebody else that you can do
it better than them so even if you beat
them they still beat you yeah yeah but
the message behind that quote of you
know your haters are holding their
breath waiting for you to lose make sure
they
suffocate is is this not to change your
game because it takes a high level of
self-mastery to stay on path those that
are influenced by their haters by their
naysayers and then therefore change
their game you're absolutely right you
end up winning a game that you were
never intending to play in the first
place which is absolutely idiotic
however ever if you realize that hey the
going got tough today I may want to
throw in the towel wait a minute there's
probably people sitting out there
waiting for me to throw in the towel I'm
going to win my game for them today not
for me yeah but for them yeah right use
what you have use what you have and and
I believe again God the creator of the
universe has given us a different
emotions of of Anger of Love of
abundance of hate um jealousy those are
all tools on our tool belt to be used
appropriately now I can be absolutely
jealous and go kill someone and end up
in prison I could be jealous let's say
my wife leaves me and is with someone
else and I'm so jealous that I go kill
them I'm going to prison or I'm so
jealous that I end up becoming the even
better version of myself I still
weaponized jealousy yeah but at my game
I think that that is we could call it
the Alchemy of emotions yes right that
you get to take
something which is toxic and turn it
into something which is valuable yeah
and that's again this is a realistic
path to Enlightenment it's not to never
fear to never feel jealousy or Envy or
distaste or bitterness or resentment or
hatred or
insufficiency it's to use those things
to better yourself and the world around
you and the people that you care about
right yeah that is use what you have
yeah which is massive man most people
don't most people in
fact most people feel that they are
using everything they have to their
advantage and the life still isn't
working out in their favor when in
reality I would say they're probably
using 20% of the things that are within
their control and then they're trying to
influence the things that are outside of
their control and they're getting upset
and frustrated they can't control Biden
or the Border or the economy or
inflation but what are all the things
that you can control can you control
what you're about to eat next when
you're going to sleep what your what
text messages you're going to respond to
what social media channels you're going
to look at that are going to give you
the sense of feeling like you're missing
out on life there's so many elements to
control yet they feel like well I'm
controlling all I can you're not even
scratching the surface let me give you
this quote from Adam Lane Smith a friend
ex psychother therapist now a
relationship coach a person obsessing
over politics is a good indicator that
their personal relationships are a mess
unless they're financially invested in
the political sphere they're probably
comp compens ating for feeling powerless
in their life o so well put beautiful
beautiful we were talking about the
internal external locus of control
mentioned to you before we started
William costell one of my friends is one
of the leading incel researchers on the
planet he is a researcher of incels not
an incel who is a researcher I need to
get that out there um but he sent me
something from uh a new article that
he's working on at the moment the
tendency for interpersonal victimhood
the ti is from uh 2020
it describes an ongoing feeling that the
self is a victim a feeling that becomes
Central to one's identity those with the
Perpetual victimhood mindset tend to
have an external locus of control and
believe that one's life is entirely
under the control of forces outside of
oneself the ti the tendency for
interpersonal victimhood is composed of
four dimensions a need for
recognition the preoccupation with
having the legitimacy of grievances
acknowledged moral elitism the belief
that the individual or their in group
behaves more morally than others a lack
of empathy and the belief that because
of their victimization an individual
cares less about the pain of others and
rumination the preoccupation with
reflecting on the past in past instances
of victimization the incel asphere I.E
the online space occupied by incels can
be characterized as fatalistic
misogynistic Echo Chambers in which
misery and failure are celebrated
emblematic of all four dimensions of the
ti
this suggests that most incels take an
external locus of control to the extreme
in perceptions of themselves and
intersex relations many incels subscribe
to a philosophy or worldview known as
the black pill a derivative of the red
pill denoting a willingness to see the
world as it really is blow to the
Blissful ignorance of taking the blue
pill my point here
is those constituent parts are present
in absolutely everybody and I have an
awful lot of of of Sympathy for the guys
who feel like the world is sort of
leaving them behind
uh who feel like they were built for a
different era uh and I see in
myself all of those need for recognition
uh the lack of empathy uh the rum maybe
not the lack of empathy actually I've
always had that but the rumination the
preoccupation with reflecting on past
instances of victimization all of that
is is very what was number two I think
number two was uh recognition four
dimensions need for recognition the
preoccupation with having the legitimacy
of grievances acknowledged moral elitism
the belief that the individual or the
ingroup behaves more morally than others
to have you know whatever grievances
acknowledged like what if you don't what
what if someone doesn't come back and
say you know what I wrong
you so what so what like like some of
those are it would be great if someone
came to me and said bados you know I I
Did You Wrong many years ago and I
apologize for that like I would want to
hear that yeah but because I don't and
therefore stay in this victimhood like
it it is it is it breaks my heart
because I'm sure these are good dudes
with the best of intentions and they
feel they're meant for another era but
in reality this is the era that again
goes back to internal versus external
locus of control well this is the era
you're in so if you can take control of
the era you're in can you then begin to
build yourself into the man who is high
value in this era I'm sure there's
things they can do plenty of them start
working out start listening to podcasts
that you actually value and get get
value from create change your circle of
influence if you're in an echo chamber
where everybody feels the same way yeah
and is just compounding your negative
feeling of yourself maybe you ought to
consider walking away from that well the
crazy thing about and this is the darker
side of the in stellosphere black pill
sort of movement is that the the number
one thing that you cannot do as a member
of that Community is what's called
Ascend given that what we were talking
about at the very beginning of this
conversation it could not be more of the
antithesis I think of the worldview that
me and you like um so
in these
communities it's not just if you were to
say that you got a girl's phone number
today that would be absolutely like
insane and unbelievable and would
absolutely get you kicked out of the
group if you were to say the Barista at
Starbuck's eyes lingered on you for
longer than you thought was normal today
that maybe there's a glimmer of hope and
the reason that ascending or even the
inclination of Ascension is so
disparaged
in the black pill commun at least in the
incel community black pill is slightly
different in the incel community the
reason it's so disparaged is that I
think it gives hope right oh well maybe
this isn't completely just
fatalistically determined and at the
mercy of the universe because if this
person was able to enact some change or
have a good thing happen to them maybe
that can happen to me and as soon as you
posit hope you then posit the potential
for disappointment right yeah it's sour
grapes at an existential level yeah
that's what you want and and also hope
also once you have hope you are forced
then to take action next Y and let's
take it the reality is in action sitting
there playing their video games Cheeto
dust in their belly buttons in their
mom's basement is far more convenient
and requires less effort and less
momentum and less inertia than actually
feeling hope and therefore taking action
cuz if that guy actually let's let's use
that guy he went to Starbucks to Barista
actually smiled and gave him a wink and
then on the uh on the hot cup of chai
latte her there was her phone number and
he shared this in the group now he's got
hope whether he shares it or not now he
has to take action he's going to have to
call her if he calls her now she says
yes let's go out he's going to have to
comb his hair brush his teeth my God he
might actually have to bathe like look
at the series of actions and if she
actually likes him he may decide I got
to work out to keep her there's a series
of actions that these guys don't want to
take again I believe the incel community
is the most toxic damaging community and
it's a bucket of crabs you know how
bucket of crabs operate right and let's
let's share it for your audience like if
there's a five gallon bucket of crabs
there's no lid required for that bucket
of crabs because when the ambitious crab
begins to climb on top of the rest and
you know starts lifting itself up by
grabbing the rim of that bucket
instinctively those crabs at the bottom
will grab their legs and pull them down
and so the fisherman never has to put a
lid on the bucket of crabs that are
alive because he knows that they will
police each other and pull them down
that is the incel community and so they
they absolutely look down upon hope
because hope leads to action and action
means that you might free yourself from
here and that also does something else
holy that holds a mirror up to me
and says I might have to actually take
some action and well that's inconvenient
I'd rather jack off to pornhhub or or
only fans and keep playing my video
games versus actually put some sunlight
on my body and get rid of my G Latinos
body and do something like decent like
string a pair of words together that
make a cohesive sentence well it's more
comfortable to get fatalistic and call
it pragmatism right like the cope is
framing hope as naivity
right and and there is I see this I see
this in it kind of appears almost in in
other ways as well you know look at
the look at the sort of intellectual
heterodox Community there is something
alluring and kind sexy and aloof about
having a contrarian point of view right
or being a cynic in some ways and you go
well are you sophisticated like is that
have you arrived at this world view
through being sophisticated or is this
just the exact inverse of whatever the
mainstream believes right being a black
sheep is still being a sheep MH you're
no smarter by just doing the exact
opposite of whatever the mainstream
tells you corre it's no more
sophisticated of view it is precisely as
UNS phisticated Just In Reverse in
reverse and this is no different than
what we talked about earlier when
we when we said that the
uh these
guys in the incel community are probably
lacking purpose any sense of purpose
fulfillment significance let's be honest
and significance is one of the core
fundamental needs of any human like you
want to feel like you you you matter and
so you know what if I can hang out in
this Echo chamber on this you know
Reddit board or comment section of this
YouTube channel
and this could be my purpose I could be
the guy just constantly beating the drum
and be part of this community it is a
community and we want to belong to a
community yeah it's unfortunately a
community that's toxic it's negative and
it's so it's so damaging and when those
that have any sense of hope as you said
get stifled so quickly well it's
disincentivized it's actively
disincentivized right to do a thing that
would pull you out of it and dude I see
it I see you know if you get
behaviorally Behavior genetics redpilled
um you know you realize that an awful
lot of the outcomes that you have your
potential in life is very very heavily
uh predisposed by the genetic sort of
raw material that you were given and
then on top of that you know random
chance and the environment and the
events that you encounter in life also
have that there are just layers and
layers and layers of things that are
outside of your control and it I
completely understand why people can
become transfixed by that yeah yeah it
it it breaks my heart but it does not
absolve them from what they need to hear
which
is they are still losers and they are
actively living
as part of the unwashed masses and they
will continue to stay peasants and will
soon as they get older come to the
realization that a decade has gone by
and valuable time has been wasted and
they need to hear this as much as my
heart bleeds for them and I wish I could
just parachute into the incel
annual World Conference convention and
Shake Everyone by the shoulder and just
say let's go like that's what I would do
if I could but I can't so they need to
hear the message that a decade's going
to go by and they're going to see things
and feel things differently and realize
that time was absolutely wasted and you
will never get it back you say the
emotionally immature man seeks out
motivation to do something hard one time
the emotionally mature man uses
discipline to do something hard a
thousand
times why is emotional maturity related
to motivation and discipline good
question because when you have emotional
maturity you realize that some days
you're not going to sleep well some days
you're going to wake up and you've got
your schedule and everything's planned
out and the poop hits the fan you got to
eat those sandwiches right and
whether things go well or not that day
the emotionally mature man will still do
what he has to do to stack his winds to
focus on his purpose whereas the
emotionally immature man will say well I
didn't sleep well I had nightmares so
I'll stay in bed I didn't sleep well or
uh it's raining outside it's cold
outside I don't feel good the I just
woke up and the airplanes hit the World
Trade Center so I guess I have to change
my pattern of life you have to stay the
course no matter what and it takes a
high level of emotional maturity because
your emotions dictate your motion like
what you're going to do and so if you
have emotional maturity you're more
likely to lean into discipline when
things are
suboptimal if you lack emotional
maturity then how you feel determines
what you do next which is very damaging
to outcom driven humans yeah I felt this
in myself uh the I sort of talked about
the thinness of the line that you walk
between seeing just how close you came
to not doing a thing but it's not the
life Direction and where your world
could have ended up it's literally every
s single interaction that you do all of
the time so I had a I'm doing these live
shows at the moment or I will do a full
live tour around uh Island UK then Dubai
then the US and Canada toward the back
end of this year and I decided that I
was going to do work in progress shows
like how comedians do them because I
wanted to kind of move through the
material and see how it gets responded
to on stage and then maybe make some
adjustments to how I was presenting it
and also become comfortable right like
you've spoken in front of big groups
terrifying so I uh I want I
wanted to I wanted to spend some time on
stage and um the way that I was feeling
in the week leading up
to these work in progress
shows
was by the way this is delicious bro you
happy with that that is I'm not kidding
this is amazingly D we we worked
unbelievably hard on that thank you yeah
six months of taste testing to get that
puppy right nailed it hell yeah so we
are I I was feeling pretty shitty and
then it's like I've got the show on the
Monday and this is the first one of the
work in progress shows and it's all the
rest of
it and I've got Co right and say
what you want for the people out there
I'm all for Co only killed like you know
the old and the unhealthy and the people
with the predisposition and all the rest
of it like lockdowns were over the top
and we didn't need to respond in the way
that we did in all the rest of it let me
tell you it is no joke right I'm
35 with four figure testosterone and it
killed me it absolutely sideswiped me
and then I'm out the other side I test I
test negative for being able to like
whatever I've had I've done the
incubation period so I know that I'm
fine to do the show but I still feel
like absolute dog my HRV is in the
tank my resting heart rats through the
roof even like my blood oxygen isn't
there you can tell that I use a woop and
uh I'm just and I feel my felt senses
thoughts are muddy um coughing throat's
not clear uh my my speech and diction
coach um miles who is usually very um
he's PRO voice rest for stuff like this
uh and I had a couple of I had like a
little Council you the Council of Elders
that I had to tap into uh Jimmy Carr
said that he thought I shouldn't do it
because he said look you're so early on
in your life tour career that if you
have a bad show it might knock your
confidence and that could be a difficult
spiral Cascade to to get back out of I
spoke to Miles and Miles said
I think that you should do it because I
think that it's a good opportunity to
get on stage the reason that I did it
because I'm still fundamentally
psychotic is that I realized if I was
able to perform well on
stage only seven days after I'd had
covid still feeling like dog that
when I'm on tour we're doing Edmonton
and Calgary and Toronto in the middle of
December if I'm freezing cold and we've
slept in some House hotel or maybe
the flight got canceled and we haven't
slept at all and we've been in the
Airport
overnight how hard is this going to be I
did it with I did it just
recovering from covid so it was like a
flag that I was planting in the ground
to prove to myself this is the level
that I can get to yeah right we did uh
recently in La we did all of these shows
back to back to back to back to back
first off because there was tons of
people that I was super super excited to
speak to like
today come to La this just I'm swimming
in interesting people so I want to do it
but there's going to be a price that I
need to pay right and it's like okay
well where's the bar that I can set
myself and this is the coolest thing
like not talking about not to one
anymore we're now talking about 95 to 96
or 96 to 97
right when you actually think okay this
is where I previously thought my limit
was and don't get me wrong I'm having
conversations sat down with
interesting people fueled by caffeine
right like just mainlining it into my
veins okay like I'm not I'm not doing
the 75 hours of of of like seal like
selection that you guys do but
I was like okay this is where I thought
my limit was for this let's just see if
we can nudge this a little bit and this
Strategic Learning opportunity right you
either like win or you learn the
Strategic Learning opportunity of what
does this mean for me if I can do it and
importantly if it doesn't go well as
opposed to saying this makes me uh less
of a person in an inferior okay what do
I need to do in order to nudge my
capacity to be able to get there and we
can see it with whatever it is that you
want to care about right can I do 15
minutes of meditation instead of 10 can
I not hit the snooze button for a full
week in a row and if I don't I don't
moralize about it I don't tell myself
some sort of a story about what this
means about me as a person what I do is
I say okay what do I need to do to be
able to achieve this and I think it's
just such a like that framing it it
comes to me when I'm in my best moments
right when I'm my least juvenile my
least bitter my least resentful
and that version of me like treating
myself like a friend that I'm
responsible for helping in Jordan
Peterson language is like there's no
losing there's no losing and it feels so
fulfilling and I remember the texture of
my mind when I didn't have that
self-love when my selft talk wasn't
there and yeah man I mean hell
like I am absolutely patient zero for
being someone that thought that wasn't
friends with with his inner voice well
that I mean that's what we need most
right so we we we teach what we need
most and so what you've done is you've
gone from the zero to whatever like as
you said in the high 90s and now that's
that's what you're teaching and you're
good at teaching it because it's coming
from real life experience versus I've
read these thousand books on self-growth
self-help but I'm still a human
animal behind closed doors but I'm just
going to pair it off what I've heard but
to that point I'm so glad you did that
show even while feeling like dog um
having even you know while you weren't
contagious I can I can confirm that when
I had covid it was definitely like I got
hit by a semi and all 18 tires ran over
me like again I agree with you in every
way you should have your right to choose
whether you're going to get the jab or
not and we shouldn't have had the
lockdowns and Etc but it definitely hits
you different than the common cold or
the flu at least it did for me as well
so but that said I think people most of
us are aware of IQ and EQ and I think
the factor that most people aren't aware
of is the AQ the adversity quotient and
that if you could do something that you
would normally do in
a under duress so your body's trying to
recover your lungs are trying to recover
and you're doing something that you
planned on doing in perfect health now
you're doing it under suboptimal
conditions you are increasing your
adversity quotient your ability to deal
and with adversity and maintain
composure for a prolonged period of time
that then directly has influ inuence on
the IQ and EQ as well it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy because you're
like holy if I could do this per
else can do what else can I do it gives
you a high level of
Competency and therefore confidence
there's a competency confidence Loop
right and it goes well maybe I can
actually invest in increasing my
intelligence more I can probably become
a more emotionally connected human that
then allows you to go I can probably do
more things under duress higher at
adversity coent yeah Ryan holiday says
self-belief is overrated I prefer
evidence MH and that was a like a
strategic piece of evidence and it it
was probably risky right looking back I
don't know how risky it was but I was
able to do it and I'm like oh cool well
you know if I if I step out on stage and
all hell breaks loose and the lights go
out and all the rest of it like I still
might myself but I've at least got
one kind of difficult thing that I
overcame that makes me feel like
yeah I feel good about myself for having
done that so but going back to what you
said real quick remember what you're
going to say you said something so
profound earlier that line where you
made that decision to go on stage versus
not y or you consulted with your elders
and ultimately you made that decision
let's say all the elders said bro stay
in bed recover and you're like it
disregarded that line is so thin man it
is so easy to justify and negotiate with
your inner self and go it I'll stay
in bed and then only to realize I just
stacked a big L right and that line is
super thin and if we can just cross that
Chasm into doing what's right which is
choose adversity under duress and watch
how you continue to turn up that
thermostat yeah of the high that's how
people get to you know you look at
anybody that's done anything
particularly spectacular in their life
and you think how is someone able to
achieve this work rate you know I often
look at Rogan and I Think Jesus
Christ man like the the the show the the
comedy the UFC the
family the and the Leisure Time and the
friends and stuff like that and I'm like
wow like even from me someone that's
seen it firsthand it's still like a it's
like the guy's got 36 hours in the day
or something like that but the thing
that you realize as you reflect on your
own ability to progress is
well I see my development I see where my
life used to be and my capacity used to
be and I remember the texture of my own
mind a little bit I always used to think
it'd be really cool you know he can take
a photo and that's kind of a snapshot in
time of what you can see I'd love to be
able to take a snapshot in mind of the
texture of your own existence and be
able to go back and visit it right what
would you like to be uh 2013 Chris let
me just drop in for five minutes oh my
god do you remember all of the things
that used to capture my attention and
the fears I had and the rumination wow I
didn't even I didn't even realize that
this was an entire world that I could
tap it and then you get to get pulled
back out of it and getting you know
because we you you can even see the
number on the scale the difference in
the photos of your body like the
development but the development of the
texture of your own mind you can only
ever experience your past experience
through the experience you have now and
it limits your theory of mind for
yourself for your past self right and I
I thought it would be cool if there was
maybe Elon with new link will be able to
make I was say if anyone's going to pull
that off it's going to be Elon but what
think about what an advantage it would
give us to see like how much growth
we've had or how much we haven't a
de decades gone by and still that guy
complaining about the government and
taxes and inflation and what's happening
instead of actually becoming the hero in
my own Journey yeah right what are
you doing next what can people expect
from you soon uh so I'm actually working
on a second book now uh ManUp was my
first book came out in 2018 and it's
done really well and my show uh the
bedrose Coan show really popped off
thankfully this last 12 months and
quadrupled my book sale so it went from
great to extraordinary uh that that
inspired me to write my next book uh
which I've got a working title so I'm
not going to share it here what are you
thinking about for as a broad subject
area what I'm thinking about the broad
subject is is
is it's still going to be in this
self-development
genre but it is I'm finding more and
more evidence that change can really
take place in an instant and that it
doesn't have to be this massive long
painful Journey the change can take
place in an instant almost of a flip of
a switch if you will uh and and so I'm
through my own personal experience and
through the experience of those that I
coach and consult I've kind of almost
figured out this hack of creating change
quickly and then maintaining that
change new identity and so I want to be
able to share that because I think most
people who want to produce change and
become the best version of themselves
the work ahead of them overwhelms them
yeah and I think that there is a shorter
path to it but still requires work make
no mistake about it and it is very it's
it's it's you know what it's like the
project I was telling the guys so
yesterday you know we finished running
the project 75 hour men's personal
development experience uh focused on
those five FS Faith Family Fitness
Finance fulfillment and I said fellas
remember we had you for 75 hours so you
can't go home and expect your wife to
automatically wake up at 4:00 a.m. or
whatever time you want her to wake up
and attack her dreams and so
like we had you and the the marine and
the seal and and these guys like forced
you into doing the things and increasing
your capacity in 75 hours like they were
able to lead better in 75 hours they
able to communicate better they were
able to problem solve better they were
able to work as a team better and those
are the four fundamental things you need
in life all of life consists of
communication teamwork problem solving
and Leadership um a and so but that's
because they are in the pressure cooker
of the project I said you can't go home
and expect your family to all of a
sudden fall in line cuz running the
first two or three class of the project
I would get messages from the wives like
holy you guys created a monster
like I don't want to wake up at this
time and then go to the gym twice a day
and then also attack this part of my
life and the meditation and the work and
then figure out what my next phase of
life is going to look like before this
phase is over all right great I get it
you know what let's start telling these
guys hey ease your family into it over a
90-day period let's pick one pillar of
the Five Pillars and ease them into it
over a 90-day period and so I think the
same thing applies here like there is it
is going to take hard work but there is
a compressed way to be able to flip the
switch and find that new identity and
then become that person virtually
overnight but it's a still requires hard
and heavy work I think that's sort of
formative experiences right like people
have been through things sometimes it's
trauma sometimes it's a loss sometimes
it's Tony robbin's event you know what I
mean like there's things that happen
that are just so important to people and
and wow I mean if you could self
generate that if you could not have to
wait for the world to give you the input
to be able to make that happen if you
could to manufacture that element that
will trigger the change is huge yeah
yeah that's cool yeah bed Ros kulan
ladies and gentlemen dude I really
appreciate you thank you for coming to
see me where should people go they want
to follow your work yeah yeah so first
off Chris thank you thank you for the
opportunity man I'm a big fan of your
show and I really appreciate the uh
opportunity you've given me here uh
secondly best place to find me is either
on YouTube or instagam
bed Ross Coan hell yeah bed Ross thank
you man thank you thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode with bed Ross you will love my
conversation with Andrew hubman which is
3 hours long and brand new go
on give it a press